[تصفيق]
طفله صغيره طبيعي انها تكون فضوليه وزي اي
طفل عمو يلعب ويجرب اشياء جديده لكن انك
تيجي تحكي له عن موضوع المستقبل اكيد رح
يكون جوابه شو يعني وهذا حال جميع الاطفال
هالطفله شدها بيوم من الايام صوت الزوار
اللي كانوا موجودين عندهم وهي عمالها
بتسمع من ورا الباب زي الحراميه اه لكن هي
كانت قاعده بتسمع سمعت اصوات غريبه الاشي
الوحيد اللي هي ممكن تحكيه انه اصوات يمكن
مش عرب
بعد ما خلص الموضوع سالت الوالد بخصوص هذا
الاصوات اللي كانت عمالها بتسمعها وحكى
لها هدول الضيوف موجودين عنا وبيحكوا
انجليزي
بيحكوا انجليزي ومن هون شراره كانت بشكل
غير مدرك موجوده في عقل هاي البنت الصغيره
وفعلا مع مرور الايام البنت نشات على
الرغبه شديده وميول تجاه اللغات الانجليزي
الفرنسي وكان واضح جدا من تصرفاتها ومن
طريقه حكيها يوم عن يوم كانت تستمتع اكثر
في الموضوع وكان يشدها اكثر واهلها كانوا
ملاحظين هذا الشيء مرت الايام كانت زيها
زي اي طالبه تانيه متفوقه جدا في المدرسه
بتمشي بدون تفكير مسبق بالاحداث ولكن
الاحداث لحالها بتاخذها وفعلا خلصت
المرحله الابتدائيه وبعديها وصلت للمرحله
الثانويه لكن هون كانت عندها نقطه التوقف
ممكن جدا ادخل السلك العلمي وبعديها اصير
دكتوره او مهندسه وشيء جدا بالنسبه لهذه
الطفله ممكن انها تعمله ولكن يمكن مش
طريقه وبالخيار الثاني في شيء هي جدا
بستهويها وبحبها وهو يمكن يكون النقيض
لهذاك التيار هل امشي مع الشيء اللي فعلا
انا بحبه وموهبه جدا فيه ولا هل امشي مع
الشيء اللي بمشي معدلي وانجازاتي
الاكاديميه
الجواب كان ورق صغيره عليها رقم 97
دقه على باب المديره وكلمه تفضلي يا ترى
شو اللي صار اللي صار هو اسئله كتيره
وحيره كبيره كلنا بنتعرض لها وكلنا بننحط
فيها في مواقف كثيره ما بين الاختيار
بين الرغبه والميول والهوايه وما بين
الشيء المنطقي لما يجي حدا يحكي لك انت
بالقلم والورقه شاطر وروح عليه والقرار
كان ورق التحويل فرع تقدمت للمديره في اول
يوم في الثانويه العامه المديره رفضت طبعا
والجواب كان انا رح اجيب معدل تفوق اولا
ثانيا راح ادرس منحه ثالثا رح اتخصص لغه
انجليزيه
هاي كانت اكثر لحظات حياه هذه الطفله يعني
حياتي انا ادراك وثقه وطموح لانه هاي
الطفله بدها تصير زي والدها اللي سمعته من
ورا الباب مترجمه رائعه ومبدعه وبالفعل
اللي بيمشي بطريق عن وعي وادراك وطموح
بهون عليه كل الصعاب اللي بيشوفها بهاي
الطريق
وبعديها مشيت الايام ام خلينا ننتقل ليوم
ثانويه العامه واعلان النتائج وصلت
الرساله الرساله فيها
98.7 كمان مره 98.7 انا ما كنت مدركه اني
راح اوصل لهذا الرقم لكن الجهد كان موجود
على الورقه كتبت للمديره 97 جبت اعلى من
الرقم اللي انا بدي اياه وطلعت الاولى على
الجنوب واخذت منحه رئيس وتخصص لغه
انجليزيه وبعد هذا الحكي
انتم متخيلين انه الواحد يسمع كلام زي يجي
واحد يحكي له شو قايم عليه بتدخل انجليزي
انت هيك بتقلل من مستواك حدا ثاني ممكن
يجي يحكي لك انت تعبك راح يروح على الفاضي
لانك رح تدخل تخصص معدل قبوله اقل جدا من
المعادله اللي انت تعبت وقتلت حالك علشان
تجيبه
جوابي كان اني اكتفي بالابتسامه وهلا رح
احكيلكو ليش
بعد ما خلصنا موضوع التوجيه انتقلنا على
موضوع البكالوريا انهيت البكالوريا لغه
انجليزيه فرعي فرنسي في جامعه الخليل
واخذت مرتبه شرف وطلعت الاولى على الدفعه
بعديها بلشت الخبره العمليه وتوظفت فورا
كمعلمه لغه انجليزيه طبعا الواحد مع
الخبره العمليه انتم عارفين ببلش يقالب
وشخصيته بتتغير وببلش يكتسب خبرات جديده
من كل حد بين وصو في هذه الاثناء كان عندي
فكره بتحكي انه البني ادم اذا بده يكمل
ماجستير لغه انجليزيه وكلكم عارفين بعد
البكالوريا بنطمح لماجستير لازم على
الاغلب ياخذها بره الولد على برا البلد
اسفه علشان الاكسنت انتم عارفين ولكن مش
كل الطرق اللي بيرسمها غيرك الك بتنطبق
عليك
وبالفعل بعد سنتين انتقلت لجامعه البولي
تكنيك وبلشت شغل فيها على البارتايم وفي
نفس الوقت بلشت ماجستير ترجمه تحريريه
وشفويه في جامعه القدس ابو ديس فيها
احداث نقله نوعيه في نموذج التعليم اللغه
الانجليزيه كيف ممكن انا اتعلم اللغه
الانجليزيه وانا بحكي وانا بمشي وانا
بتسلى
فرضا هذا اللي قدام هو عباره عن نموذج
لكيفيه تعلم اللغه الانجليزيه
بس تعرف تحكي اسمك احكي وبالفعل كنا مع
بعض نقوي بعض مع جروب من السياح كانوا
يجوا بشكل متوالي كمان النموذج اللي
قدامكم عباره عن واحد من الانشطه اللي
كانت موجوده في ايام البولي تكنيك
استغلينا فيها كل شبر في الغرفه الارض
الجدران كل ما يمكن تتخيله يمكن استعماله
للتعليم طبقناه وهذا نموذج على لعبه
موجوده على الارض استعملناها لطلاب
المدارس كيف بيقدروا يتعلموا بس بيسكس
التعريف عن النفس بعشر على الارض
النموذج اللي قدامكم هو عباره عن نشاط
طبقناه للاطفال انتم عارفين انه الاطفال
عندهم الشعور الحسي قوي جدا واي شيء يلمس
باليد لا ينسب وعلشان هيك طبقنا موضوع
الالوان المائيه مع بصمات وكل يوم كلمه
يكتب كلمته بصمه ايده وهكذا الاقبال على
هذا التمرين كان جدا رائع خصوصا من فئه
المدارس والطلاب اللي بحبوا يجربوا بايدهم
بعد هيك كان في عنا نماذج كثيره لطلاب
ودورات كثيره اخذناها في هذه الدوره
الطلاب هم اللي قادوا العمليه التعليميه
واحنا هون بنحكي عن
نماذج كثيره للتعليم كيف يطالب يكون هو
المركز وهو اللي بيقود العمليه التعليميه
بتفاصيل كثيره
بعدين النموذج هذا رح ارجعكم عليه دخلت
مجال الرياده الاعمال عن طريق تدريس مساق
الرياده وبعديها انشات مشروع بسيط كان
اسمه اتحاد اللغه الانجليزيه
مشروع بيهدف لتغيير منظوري ومنظورك ومنظور
اي واحد عن تعليم اللغه الانجليزيه فيها
البلد وبالفعل تقدمت لمنحه وحصلت على عفوا
مش منحه حصلت على تمثيل دوله فلسطين في
مؤتمر رياده في فرنسا اسمه مؤتمر حوض
البحر المتوسط وممثله البلد في هذا
المؤتمر بهاي الفكره البسيطه
ومن بعدين انتقلت لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني وانا فيها متطوعه اضافت جدا
لشخصيتي القياديه الرياديه التحدث امام
الناس وغيره هلم جره
ومثلتهم بعتذر مثلتهم في كثير من المحافل
الدوليه هاي نموذج واحد بسيط عنهم اغلب
المحافل الدوليه كانت اون لاين على زمن
الكورونا ولليوم
بعديها قبل ما نعرض هذا الفيديو اللي راح
افرجيكم اياه
انشات فكره بسيطه بالتعاون مع راديو
ومصادر بتحكي هاي الفكره كيف انا ممكن
ادرس اللغه الانجليزيه عن طريق استعمال
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
راح اعطي لكم نموذج بسيط الهدف منه
تلاحظوا قديش ممكن ياثر عليكو حتى لو كان
الصوت مش كثير مسموع ثواني بسيطه منه
استعمال الانفوجرافيكس بتقدر تساعدك مع
وجود الترجمه تحت على انك تكتسب اشياء
كثيره موجوده في الفيديو وفي غيرها من
اساليب التعليم
احنا مش غريب علينا موضوع الانفوجرافيكس
ولكن قليل منا بطبقه في هذا البلد
بعديها في عنا نموذج ثاني
لدوره عملناها الدوره كانت صدقا انا كنت
مجرد مدير في الدوره والطلاب هم اللي
قادوا العمليه التعليميه كانت عباره عن
ندوات صغيره مصغره في اللغه الانجليزيه
كلهن منه في تخصصه وفي الامور اللي اعرف
منه نعمل تنسيق وهو نجيب الطلاب عليها
ومهمه اللي يحكوا مهارات قياده موجوده
مهارات اللغه الانجليزيه وجدت وهذا اعلان
كان موجود لهذه الدوره
هلا بجوز الصوت مش كتير قوي هو باللغه
الانجليزيه الفكره في الدوره زي ما انا
حكيت لكم هي عباره عن ادوات مصغره كانوا
الطلاب بيعقدوها ومنهم كملوا وكان انجاز
رائع جدا بعدين وصلني رابط من احد طالباتي
اللي بعدين صارت صديقاتي في طلب لتعبئه
اشي اسمه منحه زميله الشرق الاوسط مع
جامعه هارفرد فعليا انا الموضوع ما كانش
كتير داخل في بالي ولكن قدمت لاني انا بحب
ما اترك ولا اي فرصه وبالفعل بعد التصفيات
والمقابلات حصلت على منحه زماله الشرق
الاوسط مع جامعه هارفرد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واصبحت احدى الاعضاء
اكتسبنا خبرات عالميه من مختلف دول العالم
نمونا في مهارات كيف انا بقدر اشرح واحكي
كانت رائعه جدا ولا زالت لليوم وهاي
الشهاده الاولى انا اخذتها من جامعه
هارفرد وانا الصراحه بعتز وبفتخر فيها جدا
وبعدين
بعد كل هاي الانجازات يمكن حدا يجي يسالني
شو صار بالدراسه الحمد لله خلصت درجه
ماجستير الترجمه التحريريه والشفويه من
جامعه القدس ابو ديس مع مرتبه شرف ونقول
على الدفعه وبعد ما انهيت الماجستير صرت
محاضره جامعيه في جامعه القدس اللي انهيت
الماستر منها في جامعه البوليتيك وفي
جامعه الخليل بعديها واخيرا وليس اخيرا
حصلت على ختم مترجم معتمد من وزاره العدل
بعد التقدم من اكثر من 150 بني ادم وفي
الاخر صفوا خمسه والحمد لله انا كنت منهم
الفكره بعد الطريق الطويل اكيد في صعوبات
انا واجهتها وكلنا واجهناها انتو عرفتوا
انا ليش كنت ابتسم للي بيحكيلي شو قايم
عليك لانه اللي بحب طريقه هو اللي اختاره
ومدرك تماما الطريق اللي بده يمشي فيها
بيهون عليه كل الصعاب اللي بواجهها
بالطريق واحنا لسه مكملين وراح نكمل وفي
يوم من الايام راح اوصل للحلم الاكبر الي
اللي هو درجه الدكتوراه انا اليوم صرت ام
وراح ابني وامشي امشي ابني على هذا الطريق
واخليه يدرك قديش تاثيره على حياته وعلى
شخصيته
انا اليوم شاركتكم قصه بسيطه عن تجربتي
المتواضعه
بتمنى انه نرجع نلتقي كلنا محققين احلامنا
بالسعر المتواصل وشكرا سلام
[تصفيق]